but the last time you were here you you
made a promise so i'm gonna i want us
can we roll the tape just for a minute
you laugh your chickens yes what are
like maybe a couple names of your
chicken
um that was captain hook oh hi chickens
oh um captain hook uh oprah hanfrey's
next we have jennifer
and then we're gonna do ellen de generis
okay
oprah henfrey they're just throwing this
out there but kelly clarkson is cool too
i'm just saying
new chickens too and i want
just curious jennifer did you keep your
promise
listen i made a promise and i was not
joking around but i have to tell you
something all of my dang chickens
are just living i keep thinking any
minute
i'm going to need a new batch of
chickens but they are
just absolutely more like that that's so
awesome though and that was just a joke
the name thing but i do think it's so
cool that your kids are learning all
that kind of stuff i think it's really
cool
they're getting like with animals and
learning like you know having your own
headaches put on plants and go
muck out this the you know just go muck
out the coop and yeah
make sure that they you know it whenever
we have scraps of fruits and veggies
that's the first thing you know there's
always a chicken bowl to take the scraps
out to the chickens and yeah
going and collecting eggs it's great i
think it's super cool
i i promise it is it will find this is
the second time people you all were here
it's the second time
you